Bitte schön.
Schönen guten Tag, Mehmet ist mein Name.
Ich bin der Dissamander auf dieser Station und würde mit Ihnen heute das Aufnahmigesprech durchführen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, natürlich. Hauptsache, jemand guckt nach mir und hilft mir.
Jetzt kurz um Ablauf. Ich werde ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Person stellen,
dann können wir zu Ihrer Aktuellen Bescheidung.
Und wenn da werde ich ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Familie vorgeschichtet haben.
Okay, würden Sie mir verraten, wie Sie heißen?
Ja, natürlich. Ich heiße Ralf Kühler.
Ralf?
Kühler. Ich bin also ein Mann.
Herr Königs, bitte in den Vornamen, der Langsamuscht.
Ja, der Vornamen Ralf.
Und der Familienname ist Kühler, K-U-Umlaut.
H-L-E-R.
Okay. Herr Kühler.
Herr Königs, wie alt sind Sie, Herr Kühler?
Ich bin 1850.
1850.
Wann sind Sie geblieben?
Am 8. Mai 65.
8. Mai 65.
Okay, danke schön.
Wie viel wiegen Sie zu sein?
Wie viele wiegen? Das weiß ich schon. Also ziemlich genau 87 kg.
Wie groß sind Sie?
1870.
Okay.
Wie kann ich Ihnen von Herrn Kühler sagen? Was fühlt es so an?
Ja, also ich habe heute Morgen ein schlimmes Erlebnis gehabt.
Und ich bin eigentlich immer noch so ein bisschen, ja, davon so eingeschränkt.
Und bin noch unter dem Eindruck.
Ich hatte wirklich das Gefühl, ich muss jeden Augenblick tot umfallen.
Ja, ich hatte mit einmal ein ganz starkes, enge Gefühl in der Brust.
Und so ganz starke Schmerzen, brennt und dumpf.
Das hat hier oben bis in den Kieferbereich ausgestrahlt.
Und das ist gekommen, als ich mich ein bisschen angestrengt habe, ein bisschen beeilt habe.
Ich bin irgendwie zu spät losgegangen zu einem Termin, weil ich verschlafen habe.
Und dann bin ich halt dran und bin die Treppen hoch gelaufen.
Und mit einmal konnte ich nicht mehr.
Da musste ich richtig stehen bleiben und war mir schlecht.
Und zum Glück haben die Kollegen mich dann gleich in Empfang genommen.
Und die haben mich dann auch gleich...
Ja Herr Kühler, alle diese Informationen sind sehr wichtig für mich, aber ich würde gerne wissen,
ob das stimmt. Haben Sie Schmerzen hinter dem Busco?
Ja, genau.
Und diese Schmerzen sind unter Belastung aufgetreten, richtig?
Genau, ja.
Okay, ich gehe von einem Perfekt auf einen Okutes-Sendung.
Deswegen muss ich dieses Gespräch jetzt unterbrechen und ein E-Karga schreiben lassen.
Und ich sage, mein Kollege gleich Bescheid.
Okay, ja.
Herr Kollege können Sie bitte E-Karga mitbringen.
Es geht hier um eine Notfallstotzung.
Ja, wir können weitermachen.
Okay, also jetzt, wir haben das E-Karga gemacht und ich liebe immer noch.
Ja, okay.
Und ich würde gerne wissen, wie lange diese Schmerzen besteht.
Ein bisschen bestehend.
Ja, also das war nicht die ganze Zeit andauernd.
Das war vielleicht eine Viertelstunde oder so, aber mir ist es ewig lange vorgekommen.
Aber so seit haben Sie keine Schmerzen mehr, oder?
Nein, also nicht mehr solche starken Schmerzen.
Aber damals, das hat ungefähr 15 Minuten gedauert.
Ja, denke ich mal. Also wie gesagt, mir kam das ewig lang vor.
Ich hatte das Gefühl, dass ich in diesem Treppenhaus, das waren jetzt meine letzten Minuten, ja.
Und es waren sehr starke Schmerzen.
Okay, alles klar.
Und es war auch sehr angsteinflößend, muss ich sagen.
Okay, können Sie bitte mir beschreiben, wo die Schmerzengenau sind?
Sie haben mir gesagt, das war hinter dem Brustbein.
Ja, genau, also hier.
Das war der Aussteilung in den Unterkiefer.
Ja, das ging ein bisschen den Hals hoch, ja.
Und ich hatte das Gefühl, dass hiermit einmal, ob der Kiefer weh tut, ja.
Und wie ich das nicht beschmerzen habe,
Schmerzen auf einer Schmeske, von 1 bis 10,
1 steht für sehr leichte Schmerzen und 10 steht für unerträgliche Schmerzen.
Oh, das waren richtig, also das waren sehr starke Schmerzen.
Also bei 8 waren die mindestens.
Haben Sie deswegen ein Medikament reingenommen?
Nein, ich hätte jetzt nicht gewusst, was ich nehmen soll.
Und ich hatte jetzt ja auch nichts mit.
Okay, alles klar.
Gibt es bestimmte Auslöser für diese Schmerzen?
Ja, wie gesagt, ich war in Eile und bin die Treppe hoch gerannt.
Und ja, schon nach einer Treppe ist das passiert.
Und früher konnte ich problemlos, also bis in den vierten Stock hoch,
hat mir überhaupt nichts ausgemacht.
Okay, diese Schmerzen sind erst malig, ich verstehe.
Ja, also.
Was kann sie eh nicht beschreiben, hat noch schon einmal?
Dass ich so ein bisschen pusten muss, wenn ich die Treppe hoch laufe.
Das habe ich jetzt in letzter Zeit schon mal häufiger gehabt.
Ja, aber dass mir das so weh tut und dass ich solche Angstzustände kriege,
das habe ich überhaupt noch nie erlebt.
Okay, ich habe mir ja ihr Husten genau beschreiben,
weil es schneimig oder trockenal Husten.
Husten?
Ja.
Husten, Husten habe ich nicht gehabt.
Ich habe vielleicht gehört.
Okay.
Haben Sie Übelkeit oder Erbrechen?
Ja, schlecht war mir total, ich musste mich nicht übergeben.
Aber ich hatte das Gefühl, dass ich jeden Augenblick mich übergeben muss.
Okay.
Hatten Sie Fieber, Stülfros oder Nachtschweiß?
Nein, Nachtschweiß nicht.
Und Fieber habe ich natürlich jetzt auch nicht gemessen.
Aber ich weiß, wie ich da auf der Treppe saß,
dass ich gemerkt habe, dass mir der Schweiß unterläuft.
Also hinten am Rücken und am Hals, ich war klatschnass.
Okay, gibt es Probleme mit dem Stuttgarg oder beim Wasserlassen?
Normalerweise nicht.
Also ja, ich meine in meinem Alter, ich gehe manchmal nachts,
manchmal auf die Toilette.
Aber es gibt Schlafprobleme?
Schwierigkeiten, einst du schlafen, durst du schlafen?
Ja, manchmal wache ich nachts auf.
Also einmal natürlich wegen der Blase, weil ich auf die Toilette muss.
Aber manchmal habe ich das auch, dass ich nachts das Gefühl habe,
ich muss mich irgendwie aufsetzen oder das Fenster aufmachen,
weil ich nicht so gut Luft bekomme.
Das wollte ich gerade fragen.
Schlafen, müssen Sie mit erhöhtem Motorrad?
Normalerweise eigentlich nicht.
Aber manchmal ist es dann so, dass ich merke,
oh, heute muss ich mein Bett ein bisschen hochstellen.
Ja.
Okay, alles klar.
Ein Moment, ich muss alles aufschreiben.
Haben Sie etwas noch Ungewöhnliches bemerkt,
was Sie hinzufügen möchten?
Das war schon ungewöhnlich genug für mich, muss ich sagen.
Also das möchte ich nicht nochmal erleben.
Okay, ich habe jetzt eine Frage besüglich jeder Vorgehenssicht.
Gibt es wichtige Erkrankungen, von denen ich wissen sollte?
Na ja, also, was man weiß, ich habe...
Diesen Beispiel erhöhte Blutfetwerte,
Bulusuckerkrankheit oder...
Ja, ich habe ein bisschen Diabetes,
der wird seit fünf Jahren behandelt mit Formin.
Dann nehme ich eine Tablette morgens und dann habe ich...
Bitte?
Was für eine Medaille mit Formin nehmen Sie?
Eine?
Eine, eine morgens, so das sind Tausend, Tausend da mit Formin.
Und ja, also die Blutfetwerte sind auch nicht so gut.
Die sind auch ein bisschen erhöht
und ich habe auch ein bisschen hohen Blutdruck.
Deswegen nehme ich morgens auch noch einen Beta-Blocker
und dann nehme ich auch noch in der Aprilen.
In der Aprilen?
Und bitte?
Was haben Sie noch gesagt?
Das war alles, also diese Blutdruck und erhöhte Blutfetwerte.
Okay, seit wann diese Blutdruck bei Ihnen bekannt?
Ja, das hat man mal so in der Routine-Untersuchung festgestellt,
das ist so vier, fünf Jahre her.
Okay, danke schon für die Informationen.
Wurdun Sie schon mal operiert, Herr Thula?
Nee, operiert vor, die taterlich noch gar nicht.
Okay, haben Sie...
Nehmen Sie sonstige Medikamente abgesehen von mit Formin
und in der Loperin?
Nehmen Sie, regeln Sie die Medikamente ein?
Ne, sonst nichts.
Aber Sie allerginen und verträgt nicht breit?
Ja, also ich habe einmal eine Latex-Allergie,
ich muss also da mit Kontakt aufpassen,
da kriege ich einen Ausschlag davon
und was ich auch nicht vertragen kann an Medikamenten,
das ist Nauvalginen.
Da habe ich mal auch so einen Ausschlag bekommen
und es war auch so, dass ich ein bisschen Luftnot bekommen habe darunter.
Okay, ja, ich würde gerne wissen, ob Sie vorstandig gegen Kinderkrankheit geimpft sind.
Kinderkrankheit ist alles schon lange her, doch ich würde schon sagen,
dass da alles seinerzeit gemacht worden ist, ja, ja.
Okay, sehr gut.
War Sie in letzter Zeit im Ausland?
Nein.
Lassen Sie mich überlegen.
Ich war mal ein Wochenende in den Alpen,
aber sonst, also im exotischen Ausland.
Ich würde gerne wissen, ob Sie rauchen, Herr Kühler.
Ich rauche noch wenig.
Seit zwei Jahren habe ich das deutlich reduziert,
ich rauche nur noch so zwischen fünf und zehn Zigaretten am Tag.
Früher habe ich jahrelang ganz Päckchen am Tag geraucht.
Früher, können Sie mir genau sagen, wie viel haben Sie geraucht?
Ja, also bestimmt 25 Jahre, dass ich ein Päckchen am Tag geraucht habe.
Ja, für 50 Jahre einschaut, dann haben Sie gesagt, oder?
Mhm.
Okay.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Gelegt nicht, trinke ich mal ein Glas Wein, aber nicht jeden Abend.
Aber schon so am Wochenende oder wenn es etwas zu feiern gibt?
Ja.
Wenn irgendwas gut gelaufen ist, ja, dann gibt es auch schon mal ein Glas Wein, ja.
Okay.
Ja, nächste Frage ist eine Routine Frage, die ich jedem sterben muss.
Bitte nehmen Sie sich nicht persönlich.
Nehmen Sie dortige Drogen, Herr Kühler.
Drogen?
Nein, es kann ich mir also in keiner Weise erlauben. Nein, nein.
Drogen, damit habe ich überhaupt nichts zu tun.
Nein, Sie haben mit Drogen nichts zu tun, okay.
Ja, ich habe jetzt angefragt, basically, ihr erfamilienfolge ist still.
Leben ihr Eltern noch, Herr Kühler?
Ne, mein Vater lebt nicht mehr.
Der hatte mit 83, ist ja gestorben, der hatte irgendeine Herzkrankheit,
aber ich weiß gar nicht, wo dran der tatsächlich gestorben ist,
ob das der, diese Herzkrankheit war, die ihn letztendlich umgebracht hat
oder ob das einfach auch alter Schäche war.
Okay.
Und Ihre Mutter?
Meine Mutter, die lebt noch, die hat diesen typischen Altersdiabetes.
Ja, aber ansonsten ist ja eigentlich ganz fit.
Ja, das freut mich.
Haben Sie Kinder oder Entschuldigung, haben Sie Geschevester oder Brüste?
Geschevester habe ich nicht, nein.
Ja, was sind Sie von mir, Herr Kühler?
Ich bin Innenarchitekt.
Innenarchitekt.
Ja, das klingt aber...
Und ich habe ein eigenes Büro, deswegen ist es halt manchmal stressig
und deswegen kann ich mir das eben eigentlich auch gar nicht erlauben,
um im Moment zu sein, ich muss eigentlich dringend da nach dem Rechten sehen.
Ja.
Haben Sie Kinder, sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin verheiratet, allerdings sind wir gerade im Trennungsjahr,
wir werden uns im nächsten Jahr scheiden lassen.
Ja.
Also ich lebe schon alleine.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Wir haben drei Kinder, ja.
Sie sind gesund?
Ja.
Okay Herr Kühler, ich bin für mich für wichtige Fragen durch.
Wenn Sie etwas hinzuprobieren möchten, dann wissen Sie können mir gerne sagen.
Ich möchte jetzt natürlich wissen, wie lange ich jetzt hier bleiben muss,
wann kann ich wieder zur Arbeit gehen und ja, vor allen Dingen können wir verhindern,
dass so etwas wieder passiert.
Ich verstehe, dass Ihre Arbeit für Sie wichtig ist, aber Ihre Geschevester,
wissen Sie noch, ist für uns wichtiger.
Und ich gehe von einem Verdacht auf eine richtige Notfallsituation,
deswegen müssen wir erst einmal einige Untersuchungen durchführen.
Ich werde mit meinem Obers besprechen über Ihre Situation.
Gegebenmals können Sie bei uns für ein paar Tage bleiben.
Oh je, da muss ich aber gleich dringend telefonieren,
dass mir jemand dann meine Sachen bringt und auch,
dass ich mit dem Büro telefoniere, um da alle Informationen zu geben,
was die machen sollen.
Ja.
Wir können um diese Sachen kümmern, Sie sollten erst mal keine Sorge machen.
Aber was wir machen sollen, erst mal diese Untersuchungen.
Ja, was für Untersuchungen sind das?
Ja, ich werde, wir haben schon ein EKG geschrieben und es sieht einige
Auffälligkeiten aus, diese ich mit meinem Oberarzt sprechen muss.
Und gegebenenfalls, wir können ein Echo veranlasst.
Echo-Kardiografie, das ist ähnlich wie Kardiazonografie.
Vielleicht haben Sie schon einen Sonnegefühl.
Ja, das kenne ich das Verfahren.
Ja, und es gibt weitere Bildgebende, Verfahren auch,
aber bitte erst mal, ich bitte Sie und,
dass Sie am nächsten Zimmer Platz nehmen,
Ihre Oberkörper hochmachen, damit ich mit den Untersuchungen
anfangen kann.
Und weitere Prozedere können wir danach bespielen.
Alles klar, gut.
Danke schön.
Haben Kollegen oder Kolleginnen noch andere Fragen?
Ich habe für Sie eine Frage, Herr Küler.
Hat Ihre solche Beschwerden in der letzten Zeit in Häufigkeit
zugenommen?
Ein Häufigkeit zugenommen eigentlich nicht.
Also das war sporadisch in der letzten Zeit.
Ja, also früher gab es das ja gar nicht.
Insofern hat es natürlich schon zugenommen.
Aber das war eigentlich so verteilt in den letzten Monaten,
dass das immer mal wieder vorkam, dass ich so Leichte Beschwerden hatte.
Aber so wie jetzt eben nie.
Wie lange hat es gedauert, wenn diese Beschwerden aufgetritten?
Ja, das waren immer nur ein paar Minuten.
Und dann ist das auch, habe ich mich gleich wieder geholt.
Ich habe auch längst nicht diese Angst und diese Übelkeit
und so etwas gehabt.
Sondern ich habe nur gemerkt, dass es so ein bisschen drückt
und dass ich langsam machen muss und dass ich so ein bisschen
abends Beschwerden habe.
Ja, letzte Frage.
Nehmen Sie.
Nein, nein, nein.
Okay, okay.
Ja, das war alles.
Gut.
Eine Frage.
Haben Sie starke Todesangst?
Ja, das habe ich tatsächlich gehabt.
Ja, dieses Gefühl.
Das war es jetzt.
Das habe ich auch so beschrieben.
Ja, gerade.
Okay, danke.
Ja, aber.
Bitte schön.
Scheiben Sie regelmäßig Sport?
Nicht wirklich, nein.
Also zum Sport komme ich meistens nicht.
Ja, ich fahre manchmal mit dem Fahrrad in Winter.
Da fahre ich auch manchmal ein bisschen Skis, aber sehr sporadisch.
Okay.
Ich habe auch eine Frage.
Ja.
Also Herr Küler, Sie haben schon gesagt,
dass Sie 58 Jahre alt.
Mhm.
Und vor fünf Tagen ist Ihr Geburtstag schon vorbei?
Der Geburtstag war vor, nee, am 8.
war der, das sind jetzt schon 14 Tage, 15 Tage.
15 Tage.
Ja, deswegen sind Sie jetzt 59.
Nee, ich bin 66 geboren.
Hab ich das nicht gesagt?
8., 5. der 66.
Okay, sorry, sorry.
Danke.
Darf ich noch eine Frage?
Ja.
Immer?
Ja, okay.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie haben hohe Blutfettwerte,
aber nehmen Sie Medikamente gegen?
Vorher eine Blutwerte.
Ich meine, in der April ist dagegen, ne?
Blutfettwerte, oder?
Ja.
Blutfettwerte.
In der April ist Artiläge gegen Artilägen.
Ja, dann kriegt er nichts dagegen, tatsächlich, ja.
Ja, okay.
Okay, danke.
Ich möchte einige Fragen stellen.
Gleich einige.
Dr. Gündes, machen Sie mich nicht schwach.
Ja, okay.
Sie haben gesagt, ein Viertel schtunde diese Beschwerden.
Jetzt momentan haben Sie die Schmerzen?
Nein, nein, jetzt habe ich diese krassen Schmerzen,
habe ich jetzt nicht mehr.
Nicht mehr.
Und es würde ich wahrscheinlich auch hier nicht so vergnügt sitzen.
Ja, jetzt momentan keine Schmerzen.
Und sind Sie deswegen schon bei einem anderen Arzt gewesen?
Nein, nein, ich bin direkt, die Kollegen haben mich direkt hier in die Klinik.
Ich habe früher eine Schwerde zum Beispiel.
Ja, ich bin ja regelmäßig bei meinem Hausarzt,
aber da haben wir bisher noch nichts dagegen gemacht.
Diese Fragen müssen wir stellen im FSB.
Kilowattens, Gewichtveränderung,
Übrungsstatus und Schlafstatus.
Das habe ich doch auch alles beantwortet.
Gefrackt oder?
Ja, alles beantwortet.
Okay, das war das.
Okay, gut.
Können wir als Erzgespieler anfangen?
Von mir aus immer.
Okay.
Sie müssten die Mikro anstellen bitte.
Dr. Mehmet, Sie müssten.
Entschuldigung, ja, das ist alles gut.
Ich habe einen Patienten, der ich heute aufgenommen habe.
Den ich heute aufgenommen habe, ja?
Ja, den ich heute aufgenommen habe.
Wir haben Sie einen Moment für mich?
Ja, natürlich.
Es geht um Ralf Kühler.
Herr Kühler ist 58 Jahre alt.
Er ist 65 geboren.
Er ist 58 kg schwer und 1,58 m groß.
Ein übergewichtiger Patient.
1,78 m ist er, ne?
Ja.
Ein bis 50 Jahre kleiner.
Ein übergewichtiger Patient.
Er hat sich bei uns wegen seit heute Morgen aufgetrennt.
Er hat sich mit Ausstrahlung in den Unterkiefer vorgesteckt.
Welche Schmerzen?
Wo genau diese Schmerzen?
Im Epigastriumbereich?
Nein, nicht im Epigastriumbereich.
Hinter dem Buskup?
Hinter Buskup.
Mit Ausstrahlung in den Kiefer vorgesteckt.
Der Patient hat diese Schmerzen 15 Minuten dauert.
Auf Schmerzskala liegen die Schmerzen von 10.
Diese Schmerzen sind erst mal unter Belastung.
Ich meine Treppe hochsteigen aufgetreten.
An Begleistetum sind die folgenden Begleistetum
und die Schmerzen sind auch gefallt.
Die Schmerzen sind aus Brühe, Dispene,
Palpitation und Angst, Todesgefühl.
Und die Schwierigkeiten,
die Schmerzen sind auch beschrieben.
Und die Schmerzen sind auch beschrieben.
Nein, die Schmerzen sind nicht nur in Lausia.
Nein, nur in Lausia. Keine Schmerzen.
Die Schmerzen sind aus Fibers und Schüttersprachen.
Die Schmerzen sind aus vegetarischen Analyse.
Die Schmerzen sind aus Diabetimätus seit 5 Jahren.
Die Schmerzen sind aus Epidemi.
Die Schmerzen sind aus Arterieli-Hypertoni seit 5 Jahren.
Sie haben bis jetzt keine OP erfolgt.
Sie nimmt mit Formin 1.000 mg morgens regelmäßig ein.
Und Nr. Pyril mit unbekannten mg morgens nimmt sie regelmäßig ein.
Ja, ja, ja.
Entschuldigung.
Die folgenden Medikamenten nehmen regelmäßig 1.000 mg morgens und Nr. Pyril morgens.
Er sei gegen Latex,
ein Beta-Blocher.
Ja, ein Beta-Blocher wurde auch gesagt.
Er sei gegen Latex allergisch,
die mit Exanten sich äußert.
Und eine Novalgin allergisch ist bekannt,
die sich mit Exanten und Dispner äußert.
Er sei verständlich gegen Kinderkrankheit geimpft.
Und er auch seit 2 Jahren weniger.
Er hat 5, oder 5, bis sein Zigarette pro Tag.
Aber für die 5, 15 Jahre,
ein Schachter Zigarette,
das heißt 5, 20 Packiers,
er trinkt ein Glas Wein zu bestimmten Anlassen gelegentlich.
Rogenalarmnese wurde verneint.
In der Familienalarmnese fanden sich bei Vater,
der mit 63 Lebensjahr gestorben ist,
mit unbekannten Usage,
aber es geht um hier eine Herzkrankheit,
und bei dem Mutter leidet ein Diabet Melitus 2.
Er ist in der Architekt von Beruf verheiratet
und hat Kinder, 3 Kinder haben sie gesagt, oder?
Und er lebt alleine.
Ich nachdem ich sehr gerne angehabe,
gehe ich von einem ferdach auf einen stabilen Angino-Pektor aus.
Differenzialdioknastisch können instabil Angino-Pektor aus.
Corona Herzkrankheiten und andere Karriereopathie
sind nicht verheiratet.
Worstcase Szenario ist anders.
Aber ich habe instabil Angino-Pektor.
Was machen Sie diagnostisch?
Sie haben ja schon etwas gemacht,
und was machen Sie weiter?
Nach der Köpferlichen Untersuchung und Labor.
Worauf achten Sie bei der Köpferlichen Untersuchung?
Ich würde gerne sagen, ob er Blasse hat,
oder nicht in der Inspektion.
Ich würde gerne sehen,
ob Blasse vielleicht schweißt aus.
Ich kann natürlich in Oskultation sein Herz abhören.
Das ist wichtig für uns.
Ich würde gerne Labor-Werte sehen,
mit der Bestimmung von Troponin-E, Troponin-T,
Kreitinkinas, Kreitinkinas-Mebe
und mit Infektionparametern.
Nicht Infektionparametern,
aber kleine Blutbilder.
Natürlich für uns,
ÖKG, Ökadiografie,
von Groison Medoitung,
für die Corona-Angiografie
und von Röntgenaufnahme.
Corona-Angiografie ist ja schon eine große Untersuchung.
Da müssen Sie den Patienten aufklären.
Weil das eine risikoreiche Untersuchung ist.
Dann berichten Sie mir,
wie es dem Patienten geht.
Halten Sie mich auf dem Laufenden.
Sie nehmen den auf.
Jetzt hat er keine starken Schmerzen mehr?
Er hat nicht mehr starken Schmerzen.
Aber Zugänge legen Sie ihm trotzdem jetzt.
Alles klar.
Als Therapeut,
ich habe einen schnellen Weg.
Ich habe einen Nitrosupply,
einen Nitro-Kapsil,
und ich habe einen
Ja, das habe ich verstanden, aber warum? Erst mal Aspidin.
Erst mal Aspidin, ja richtig.
Okay, gut.
Ja, also das war grundsätzlich eine schöne konsequente Anamnese und auch Wiedergabe.
Ich muss gerade mal gucken. Ich habe mir wenig aufgeschrieben, was mir aufgefallen ist mit den Zahlen.
Ich glaube, da habe ich am Anfang selber den Fehler gemacht, dass ich mein Geburtstjahr falsch angegeben habe.
Das hat ja auch ein Kollege schon korrigiert.
Ich bin natürlich 66 geboren, ich 65, wenn ich heute 58 Jahre alt bin.
Dann ist das nochmal so, der Vater ist mit 83 gestorben, nicht mit 63.
83.
Ja, also höher Fehler wahrscheinlich.
Ich habe ein Problem mit dem Nummer, ich weiß das.
Das wird bemeidigt und das ist, ich habe ein Problem mit diesem Nummer.
Mit den Zahlen, ja, die sind ja auch in Deutschland total schwierig.
Ich finde, ja auch mit den Zentimetern, Sie haben ja auch gesagt, ich wäre nur 1,58 groß.
Also 1,78 habe ich gesagt.
Also wirklich dann sehr gut hinhören und gut achtgeben und lieber nochmal nachfragen,
bevor Sie da ins falsche Fahrwasser geraten.
Wo ich nicht so ganz mit Ihnen einig bin.
Ja, Sie haben gesagt, in der vegetativen Anamnese keine Auffälligkeiten.
Sie haben aber vorher erwähnt, haben das praktisch den Nebenerscheinungen
jetzt dieser Geschichte zugeordnet.
Die Schlafstörung wegen Luftnoten.
Das würde ich eigentlich, weil er das ja schildert, dass er das schon häufiger hat.
Und so würde ich das in der vegetativen Anamnese auf alle Fälle mit erwähnen.
Und er hat gesagt, Nygtorie.
Ja, also ganz unauffällig ist die vegetative Anamnese eben nicht.
Und ja, und also eigentlich fand ich Ihre Schilderung, wie es zu dem
zu dem Notfall praktisch gekommen ist.
Da haben Sie sich sehr bedeckt gehalten.
Da hat der Patient ja einen großen Redebedarf gehabt.
Ja, wir wollte Ihnen das ja erzählen, wie das zustande gekommen ist.
Und Sie haben dann nur gesagt bei Belastung.
Und aber diese Dramatik haben Sie eigentlich der Oberärztin jetzt nicht so richtig
geschildert, dass der Patient wirklich mehr oder weniger gerannt ist und dann
zusammengebrochen und und und das eben als eine sehr dramatische Situation
erlebt hat. Ja.
Deswegen war das natürlich auch völlig richtig, dass Sie den sofort erst mal
ans EKG und Vitalparameter überprüft haben.
Genau genommen hat er wahrscheinlich schon, bevor Ihnen irgendjemand sonst näher
sieht, die erste Infusion im Arm.
Ja, weil weil das Notfallmanagement in der Klinik einfach ein bisschen
anders abläuft als in so einer Simulation.
Aber das war natürlich genau richtig, dass ich gesagt habe,
wir unterbrechen jetzt und gucken jetzt erst mal.
Ja, ich finde hier etwas sagen.
Normalerweise ich mache, was Sie mir gesagt haben.
Aber ich habe von meinem Freund dann gehört, dass ich so gleich unterbrechen.
Wenn ich diese Verdacht habe.
Das ist auch richtig.
Ja, das ist richtig. Aber diese.
Umschriftig, wenn er sei.
Nein.
Der Patient hat Todes Angst und deswegen ein bisschen
nicht so amatik.
Ja, die Information ist sehr wichtig.
Deswegen möchte ich ein Unterbrechen
brauchen und so weiter.
Aber nicht eine Diagnose stellen.
Akutes
oder ja
Probleme gibt es.
Ja, also wie das fand ich, das fand ich eben sehr konsequent zu sagen,
oh ja, wir müssen unterbrechen.
Wir machen jetzt ein paar kleine Untersuchungen.
Gleich geht es weiter mit unserem Gespräch.
Und Sie haben ja auch, geht es Ihnen denn jetzt besser?
Und der ja geht schon ein bisschen besser.
Aber so diese Angst bleibt einem in den Knochen stecken.
Das ist man ja nicht sofort los.
Gut.
Ja, aber ansonsten fand ich, war das war das
sowohl eine schöne Anamnese auch vollständig.
Sie haben nicht gefragt nach Corona-Impfung.
Das ist mir so ein bisschen aufgefallen, wenn sie schon nach Kinderkrankheiten fragen,
gehört das sicherlich heute dazu, dass man nach Corona-Impfung auch fragt.
Wenn das mal zu sagen, ich.
Aber ich mach das vergessen.
Und
ja, sie haben ja auch sehr vollständig gefasst, zum Beispiel auch Auslandsaufenthalt und
und also wirklich.
Da ist für meine Begriffe ist das sehr vollständig gewesen.
Und sie haben auch schön in der Reihenfolge die Sachen abgewickelt in ihrem Bericht.
Und ja, wie gesagt, keine Auffälligkeiten bei der Vegetative in Anamnese bin ich es nicht so ganz mit ihnen
über ein.
Und also es ist ein Münchner Fall.
Tatsächlich hat der Patienten infarkt gehabt.
Ja.
Und also aber Agnina Pectorus war natürlich als
aber aber müssen wir
müssen wir verursachen nur akutes kornes syndrome nennen.
Akute kornes syndrome drei Teile nicht
ist herbunkmio-karte infarctus ist herbunkmio-karte infarctus instabil
Agnina Pectorus drei Teile und deswegen müssen wir diese akute Situation
dann ja akute kornes syndrome nennen.
Okay.
Ja, ich denke mal, da gibt es immer Interpretationsspielraum auch je nach dem, wie ihr Patient das auch spielt.
Ja.
Und und also wie krank der jetzt drüberkommt.
Ja, das ist sicherlich auch noch mal was anderes, ob man jetzt am Bildschirm sitzt oder ob der Patient da vor ihnen sitzt und
also gleich irgendwo in den in den Seilen hängt.
Ja, na gut.
Okay. Gut.
Ja, also von mir aus.
Ich fand es eine sehr schöne Geschichte sprachlich haben sie nicht viel Schwierigkeiten gehabt, würde ich sagen.
Das war überwiegend gut verständlich und sie haben mich glaube ich auch immer gut verstanden,
dass meine Aussagen waren.
Insofern sehe ich da eigentlich keine großen Probleme.
Ja.
Dankeschön.
Okay.
Ich finde es sehr schön.
Gut.